demander à des enfants désigne un
poisson il y en a que vacciné un carré
Laurent Gerra bonsoir vous travaillez
dans l'émission rien à cirer du lundi au
vendredi à midi sur France Inter et le
dimanche de midi de 10h du matin à midi
2h en direct alors Laurent Gerra vous
aussi vous portez des cravates c'est
pour imiter coffre ou exactement parce
que je suis vraiment heureux d'être
invité dans cette émission en nom de
Dieu parce que c'est une émission qui
tourne autour des femmes et les femmes
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la fraîcheur
c'est la convivialité c'est merveilleux
regardez-moi ça alors surtout ici
surtout ici c'est pas des animatrices
comme on en voyant polyphosphaté ici
c'est la fin c'est tout est bon c'est
comme dans le cochon voilà alors non pas
juste un proche à faire quand même à
toutes ces dames pendant qu'elles font
les missions qu'est-ce qui fait bouffer
parce qu'on a retiré les bonnes femmes
des fourneaux quand même
important on a de bons produits alors
bien sûr on fait la cuisine elle va vite
maintenant le poisson il y a plus de
poissons
un poisson il y en a que dessiner
un carré
c'est la même chose de jambon maintenant
c'est de la merde c'est plein de flotte
c'est polyphosphaté le riz on en a même
plus on a un tout envoyé en sommeil et
puis alors la salade je vous en parle
quand même c'est quand même pas bien
compliqué de faire sa salade soi-même
que d'acheter ses saloperies qui ne
respire pas dans du plastique vous
prenez votre cadeau donner une recette
prenez votre salade ou la mettez dans
l'eau avec un peu de vinaigre en
portugais les bestioles et les limaces
parce que il faut bien et vous avez et
puis vous avez le toucher avec le
produit c'est merveilleux et formidable
vous allez me dire c'est long c'est long
enfin quand vous faites l'amour la
longueur c'est le plaisir non
c'est la période de Noël alors c'est une
période où on se fait arnaquer nom de
Dieu il faut le savoir il faut le dire
au consommateurs
on écoute n'importe qui alors tiens par
exemple tous les toutes les années on
nous met Denise Fabre qui nous vient qui
vient nous dire comment découper une
dinde mais comment voulez-vous qu'on la
croit elle elle est tout entière
pas ses poulets prêtes à cuire c'est de
la merde il faut bien le savoir c'est
des poulets qui ne voient jamais pour
choisir un poulet il faut qu'il ait les
pâtes et le bec pourquoi les pas parce
qu'on voit s'il a couru
pourquoi le bec parce qu'on voit ce
qu'il a bouffé non de dieu et s'il a
bouffer de la merde
alors c'est Laurent geral vous
connaissiez pas Jean-Pierre Coffe me dit
qu'il y a tous les matins sur France
Inter un type qui m'imite formidablement
et moi c'est l'heure à laquelle je
prépare l'émission sur Canal donc j'ai
jamais l'occasion de l'écouter et là
vous pouvez pas savoir ce que ça m'a
fait c'est vous non c'est pas ça c'est
que je pendant qu'il parlait je me
disais esquivadire ça parce que bon il y
a deux trois tubes qui m'imitent et je
trouve que jamais il trouve jamais les
mots et il tremble trop parce que bon
moi je trempe parce que je vois trop de
vin blanc c'est tout c'est pas parti
mais là vous pouvez pas savoir comme je
suis heureuse de vous avoir vu ça
tous les soirs à
21h15 et ben bon donc à Millau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]